[Musique]
bienvenue dans un nouveau débat des
élections municipales et communautaires
2020 édition dédiée donc que cette fois
à rivière-pilote avec 5 candidats têtes
de liste autour de la table de notre
studio bonsoir messieurs et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
un débat qui sera animé donc avec pedro
monnerville bonsoir pedro bon sens
avertin on sera tous voila et nous
commençons tout de suite par la
présentation justement des candidats
pedro est absolument cinq candidats vont
à midi et tout d'abord jean françois
bonhomme bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
monnaie revue nous avait 57 ans vous
êtes directeur de la fédération des
maisons familiales rurales de martinique
vous êtes sans étiquette vous avez été
longtemps l'a peut être oublié mais
l'important de le rappeler longtemps
attaché parlementaire de pierre petit et
vous êtes donc tête de liste agir pour
rivière-pilote merci à vous d'être
larmes denis louis gisement soit vous
avez 46 ans vous êtes cadre technique
adjoint en bureautique en informatique
vous êtes un ex du mime désormais
adhérents le payant alors pas
d'investiture pour cette élection ça
vous a pas empêché de vous présenter
puisque vous dirigez la tête vous êtes
tête de liste no cry ville pilote en
action edouard marrant bonsoir 72 ans
bonsoir secrétaire administratif à la rs
vous êtes membre du même boulot dit
alors vous êtes président du comité
patriotes de rivière pilote vous êtes la
tête de liste assemblée populaire
municipal
deux autres candidats donc pour ce débat
raymond théodose bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le maire sortante est âgé de 64 ans
employé de banque à la retraite
vous êtes membre du groupe politique
dynamique pilotine et vous êtes à la
tête de la liste qui porte le même nom
dynamique pilotine et puis le cinquième
candidat dans l'ordre de présentation et
victor vladimir veilleurs bonsoir
bonsoir messieurs
âgé de 47 ans ingénieur informaticien
d'une société de crédit
votre groupe politique est baptisé
l'unité pilotine c'est également le nom
de la liste dont vous êtes à la tête
vous vous réclamez du soutien du mime et
surtout d'alfred marie-jeanne lui-même
et puis faut-il le préciser le préciser
vous êtes le fils de l'ancien maire de
rivière pilote lucien veilleur voilà
pour les présentations
avant de commencer enfin nous allons
commencer plus tôt par un micro trottoir
vous savez c'est l'exercice habituel
là c'est bien qu'à bien le cas car eto'o
qui donc effectivement s'est rendu ce
matin dans le centre bourg et dans la
périphérie du bourg de rivière pilote
pour interroger quelques habitants et
quelques habitants on écoute et puis
ensuite pedro monnerville vous vous fera
réagir
nous devrions avoir le micro trottoir
alors d ici à ce qu'on retrouve cet
élément pedro on va faire une
présentation succincte du bourg de la
ville de rivière qui n'a absolument une
présentation assez rapide effectivement
de la ville de rivière pilote communes
du sud de l'île vous le savez avec une
superficie d'un peu plus de 35
kilomètres carrés villes limitrophes
donc de sainte-luce du saint-esprit du
vauclin encore du marin il vient pilote
ces onze 1925 habitants soit une baisse
de près de 6 % de sa population par
rapport l'an can 2012 est bien pilote
c'est une terre à multiples facettes
c'est une terre de résistance
on le sait tous avec une histoire riche
à l'image de l'insurrection du sud en
septembre 1870 une terre touristique
également avec l'une des plages les plus
fréquentées de l'île ans filles et c'est
une terre de rome avec sa distillerie
la ministère de patrimoine également et
son écomusée et enfin terre de sport
avec les exploits malheureusement pas
c'est peut-être à venir du fameux racing
club de rivière bleue on se souvient
tous avec des noms célèbres comme la
gibier entre autres
voilà et puis donc qui ont marqué donc
l'histoire du football martiniquais les
habitants devient pilotes sont appelés
les pilotins et le nom de rivière-pilote
chose importante également à dire viens
d'un amérindien baptisé pilotes avec
deux t il faut le préciser
qui se serait donc loyers dans la
rivière éponyme c'est à dire qui porte
donc le même nom que la commune
d'aujourd'hui bertrand merci merci
beaucoup pedro pour cette présentation
donc de la ville de rivière pilote
voilà nous allons écouter donc
maintenant quelques pilota et pilotine
du sud je sais pas si c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle sud pilotin comment
comment appelle-t-on les et puis l'autre
le pilotage à huawei et se cassent
pilotes alors piloter et pilotable à lui
précisé voilà du sud pour faire la
d'exception au sud et au nord bien nord
allait bien le cas car eto'o donc à
rencontrer ses habitants de rivia
quelques habitants de rivière pilote le
renouveau le changement radical si tu
joues les promesses politiques et si
c'est moi qui ai rien pour les jeunes
toujours pour ceux qui peuvent même plus
descendre au bout parce qu'ils sont déjà
fatigués donc ça sert à quoi de faire
une ambiance où des gens peuvent venir
ici la vie est morte alors que c'était
une ville très vivante donc que les
habitants même des rivières pilotes
reviennent dans les commerces de river
plate le bourg surtout est complètement
mort une craie ciment que pas mal de
choses il faudrait plus de temps aménagé
un petit peu la sig et voilà des espaces
de loisirs
il n'y a pas une salle de sport il n'y a
plus eu de cesse de descendre aux enfers
on va dire est qu'on ait du changement
et qu'on voit le changement parce qu'on
a quand même près de 12000 habitants il
ya pilote s'est par ailleurs est la
deuxième commune de l'espace sud 6,24 à
chaud quelques il ya même pas un endroit
où les propres habitants où elle se
réfugier en cas de cataclysme a besoin
deux changements se trouve la jeunesse
passionnée de sport les saintes
écritures et la paix d'activités vins
nouveaux maires qui va travailler pour
la jeunesse mais monsieur leubou ce
serait une très bonne chose
leur décision dans le temps de sentir la
vie note tout cas le court toujours et
ça c'est une très bonne chose que la
viande est bien plus qu'une étoile le
groupe le mérite notre place
je souhaite bonne chance bonne chance
monsieur merci vous l'avez entendu un
donc et pilotin du sud attendent un
changement radical au sein de votre
ville trop de promesses ils ont dit
également rien pour les jeunes un beau
quasiment mort déserté manque de crèches
pas de salle de sport d'homme dit même
également il faut qu'on arrête et le mot
effort messieurs il faut qu'on arrête
cette descente aux enfers quelle voix
dire je mènerai de la mort peut-être que
monsieur raymond théodose fait le maire
donnait enfin je crois que déjà bon
choix aux auditeurs
j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses ont pas
quoique ligne acsel peuvent se faire de
deux coups de baguette magique
je rappelle quand même qu'en cas de
calais s'initient à un refuge qui se
trouve quand même au niveau du stade de
haut niveau des écoles déjà et au niveau
du stade en gamme et donc il faudrait
quand même que les pilotis sorte un
petit peu pour savoir quand même ce qui
se passe sur leur commune ne pas être
aussi fataliste
notre réaction peut être jean françois
bonhomme écoutez quand je partage
complètement les commentaires et
proposer mes compatriotes
permettez-moi d'abord de saluer deux
pilotes 1 et la population martiniquaise
qui nous écoutent
j'étais candidat en 2001 j'ai annoncé
j'ai alerté sur le déclin de cette ville
ma chance j'ai dans mes papiers toutes
mes déclarations de 2001 j'ai encore en
2008 posé sur la table le déclin de la
ville l'insuffisance de réponse des élus
le grand pour nous c'est que vous avez
une ville qui ont 61 ans avait onze
mille habitants nous sommes en 2020 nous
sommes autour de 11000 kabylie ya
quelque chose qui s'est pas fait
deuxième problème c'est que nous avons
élus
d'importantes personnalités à la tête de
ce pays et nous avons fait des
présidents de région présidents de
départements députés et en retour nous
notre génération nous constatons que
notre ville est complètement morte est
le nôtre bout est en train de s'éteindre
lentement je n'accuse pas le métier là
on envoie tout à l'heure on reparlait
mais quand même c'est toute une
stratégie politique qui n'a pas pu se
mettre en place qui n'a pas été mise en
place depuis janvier 23 ans
donc nous nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
la confrontation et nous devrions tous
nous mettre d'accord bout du moment là
on nous mettons nous ensemble pour new
baby la khutba nous ne pouvons plus
accepter
en 2020 la situation notre ville et je
partage complètement les propos qui ont
été tenus parce que historiquement je le
pense
voilà la suite des réactions suite à ce
micro trouve à noël la parole à monsieur
marrant oui les douars de son prénom
qu'avez vous à dire qu'elles vont
entendu ainsi aperçue qu'elle nous a
percutés
donc bon choix à la population de rugby
lot à tous les pilotes in pilotin qui
nous écoutent ça reflète en fait l'état
d'esprit alors qu'il est de
rivière-pilote nous sommes et ce que je
crains pour l'avenir c'est que on finit
par intégrer une mentalité de d'être en
bas de l'eau que la commune aux badauds
parce que effectivement il ya le dieu
rivière qui se rejoignent en plein bourg
et que maintenant nous sommes pointés du
doigt à chaque fois qu'il pleut on est
bloqués n'est viable à tabac de l'eau je
crois qu'il faut sortir de cette logique
là la rivière ne peut pas être le pup a
noyé la rivière droite est un atout avec
ses dangers mais là aussi des qualités
propose ne pas tous développé là
maintenant puisque c'est un gestionnaire
une question assez oui c'est assez large
la parole monsieur
monsieur vladimir veilleux suite à ce
mythe micro trottoir qui réflète que
même une certaine sensation de malaise
tout d'abord bonsoir c'est tous les
martiniquais et à toutes les pilotine et
puis le temps qui nous écoutent écouter
lors de nos réunions d'échangés de nous
ces mines et à des centaines de piloter
que nous avons pu rencontrer tous les
jours dans la rue c'est exactement le
bilan que nous avons fait de la ville de
rivière pilote la population de la ville
pilote n'est pas en sécurité
le maire qui est garant de la sécurité
de sa population a failli à ce niveau là
la population nous avons aussi un désir
une volonté d'un véritable changement
athlètes - changement qualitatif et pour
cela nous nous allons le développer de
terre nous avons un programme ambitieux
je dirais même audacieux
donc tout ce qui a été dit c'est ce que
nous avons entendu tous les jours dans
les rues du vieux pilote
enfin monsieur louis régis denis de son
prénom même constat également vont vous
partager un petit peu tout ce qui été
dit autour de la table ce soit autour de
la table je ne sais pas bonsoir à tous
en tout cas la population le micro tout
fort adressé un petit peu une situation
qui rit elle ras-le-bol et je crois que
si puisque aujourd'hui on constate que
certains au point un petit peu ce que
nous disons ce que nous disons qui est
de laisser dans notre programme qui est
détaillée en réunion de quartier chez
l'habitant et nous pensons également que
un certain nombre de propositions
peuvent être apportées afin de
solutionner un certain nombre de
problèmes majeurs qui gangrène notre
notre belle commune bon cela veut-il
dire que rien n'a été fait non je ne
serai pas de ceux là
en tout cas nous disons qu'il y à des
insuffisances notamment des leviers
majeurs qui n'ont pas été utilisés je
fais allusion au plus qui est un outil
indispensable indispensable et j'insiste
pour le développement et la prise de
décision concernant l'aménagement de
notre commune merci monsieur produit le
débat oui jean françois bonneau
généralement qu'un dit qu'il faut un
changement radical à maria pilote le
seul porteur de ce changement là si
j'entends ça vous aurez le temps de jeu
développé par un concitoyen encore de
tout développement dans un petit instant
alors messieurs je vous propose
effectivement quand qu'on essaie de
débattre autour de trois thématiques ce
soit la première l'aménagement et le
développement du du territoire de
rivière-pilote la seconde va tourner
autour de la petite sociales éducatives
et culturelles la troisième comment
faire justement pour que se démarquer
des autres villes ne laisse pas sud
quand on sait qu'on en ait terre comme
unité quels sont les atouts donc de
votre vie ne vient plus du puits nous
allons tenter d'aborder ce volet
politique qui nous est cher puisqu'on le
sait effectivement autour de 7,7 établir
un certain nombre de candidats qui se
revendique du parti force de rire pilote
qui est le mime alors première question
messieurs je vais vous mais je veux et
je me joins à la pause et de but en
blanc à monsieur denis louis régis on va
prendre cas de figure je suis un jeune
martiniquais ray je suis un jeune
diplômé qui sort de mes études à
l'instar d'ailleurs de nombreux jeunes
outre martiniquais qui vont pas se
laisser attirer par
les cils c'est un petit renne soit de
l'europe
voila voila ou du monde ces gens me le
dire je suis qui plus est pilotin donc
né à rivière-pilote je veux m'installer
justement arriver à une autre quels sont
donc les atouts et à tous de ma commune
pour que j'y reste
je me plante je m'y installe et que j'y
travaille il faudrait que les conditions
soient réunies
je les dix premières difficultés nous
n'avons pas de plus à rivière-pilote
celui qui aujourd'hui souhaitent
s'installer construire bâtir sa maison à
rivière-pilote il ne peut pas le faire
le plus souvent parce que sa demande de
permis de construire est rejetée donc
bien sûr et cela participe à la
diminution de notre population
il va s'installer vers les communes à
côté c'est plus marrant cet esprit etc
mais nous ce que nous proposons ce que
nous disons aux jeunes qui veulent
s'installer aux jeunes porteurs de
projets et bain dès notre arrivée nous
allons passer une convention selon les
frontières de la réglementation avec un
cabinet conseil parce que quand vous
avez un prochain vous avez les deux
poches vides
eh ben ce cabinet conseil sera là pour
accompagner le porteur de projet afin
qu'ils puissent élaborer son dossier
pour qu'ils puissent élaborer son projet
du début jusqu'à la fin et qu'ils
puissent s'installer mais nous irons
encore plus loin il y à ce qu'on appelle
des dents creuses à rivière-pilote guide
en corrèze ce sont ça peut être du
foncier nu mais également du foncier
battue bat batipart dont nous enlever
récupérer ces de creuse là et que nous
allons mettre à disposition ça se fait
ailleurs
on n'invente rien nous allons mettre à
disposition de ses porteurs de projets
gratuitement durant deux ans parce que
quand vous vous installez avec un projet
vous avez des charges fixes qui sont là
notamment le loyer et b pendant deux ans
c'est pourtant le projet que nous allons
permettre de s'installer non pas de
loyer à payer ça c'est une première
proposition c'est un premier geste fort
politique avec une volonté politique
forte que nous apportons aux porteurs de
projets jeunes ou pas je remercie
monsieur denis louis régis on va passer
donc la première thématique
l'aménagement et le développement du
territoire méritoire et plus
singulièrement peut-être du centre bourg
de rivière-pilote on l'a entendu
certains se plaignent
d'un d'un bourg plutôt morne 1 et qui
n'a pas beaucoup d'activité alors tout
ne ressort pas évidemment de la
politique de la ville
mais tout de même edouard marrant quel
constat vous faites et surtout qu'elle
vous quelles solutions vous avez où vous
proposez pour donc animé dynamiser donc
le développement du centre bourg de
rivière pilote
oui alors effectivement c'est là le le
point faible de la rivière lot
nous sommes arrivés à ce stade où j'ai
connu enfant le marché des pilotes on
pouvait pas entrer s'est tellement il y
avait du monde parce que ils viennent
l'audit et le grenier du sud et pas
seulement les pilotins qui venaient
vendre et acheter
mais les communes environnantes il
venait à arriver à bulle haute densité
un coin c'est un coin un lieu de
rencontre et ça c'est la définition d'un
bourg pour une commune
c'est un endroit qui fédère qui qui
permet qui donne le sentiment à tout à
chacun d'être d'être pilotée par
conséquent ce sera le premier défi je
crois qu'il faudra relever là avec
urgence réanimer le bout et ça passe par
avec les commerçants ne pas venir avec
un programme oui on a des emprunts du
jeu mais avec les gens qui sont
concernés directement à savoir les
commerçants les vendeurs et vendeuses et
du marché voire vécu l'animation du
bourg pour faire venir les gens donc il
ya tout c'était soit ça à exploiter
faire aussi que que le centre bourg
puissent irriguer les campagnes à
travers la production agricole qu'il
faudra évidemment attaqué qu'une
production agricole qui soit saine
inciter les jeunes à aller vers cette
branche pour que
olivier pilotes retrouvent chaque il
faisait auparavant c'est-à-dire
nourrissait la population donc il ya
tout ça à mettre en oeuvre
évidemment il ya le problème de la
rivière mais la rivière comme j'ai dit
c'est pas ses sympathies à l'état c'est
l'état qui en est propriétaire mais il
ya une pas blâmer ses qualités puisque
cette rivière qu'on le veuille ou non à
porter préjudice ou du monde à laisser
quoi que la rivière pouvait à tuer le
boer conseil et s'est noyé donc la
rivière évidemment il faudra avec l'état
avec l'espace une trouver les inciter à
draguer la rivière a ensuite avec les
commerçants les aider à mettre en place
ce qu'on appelle les barrières
anti-inondation by individuel pour
limiter la casse puisque la rivière
passe ça dieu 2h 3h 4h le temps mais
évidemment ça laisse ça laisse des
dégâts parfois et qui veut durer des
jours
donc oui alors juste une question
répondait de manière courte s'il vous
plaît pour enfin permettre aux autres de
parler mais qu'est ce qui selon vous a
empêché jusque là que ça se fasse ça
manque de volonté politique ou alors de
moyens vous avez le devoir vous avez
mais le soin la question que je pose
question c'est parce qu il a manqué
cette volonté politique la chaîne a fait
il l'a fait à certains niveaux ce qu'il
fallait
il j'avais ya aussi mais il faut
continuer la maison nous arrivons à une
droite en gros est remonté aux deux n'a
pas suivi qu'on n'a pas su faire ce que
monsieur meyer et monsieur marisa nous
fait avant mais vous avez su vous dites
que vous avez vu les c'est la population
la question il ya une manifestation mais
mes ambitions
répond je réponds aussi la réaction des
gens parfois la région des gens qui ont
qui ont manifesté à l'issue des
dernières inondations et on a dû réunir
toutes les administrations 1 pour
pouvoir comme on peut solutionner le
problème
et vous voudriez bien que la population
en attente de ça donc il ya des mesures
immédiates à prendre alors à savoir
aider vous avez déjà développé vous
allez pouvoir développer tout à leurs
noms mais yahia l'association épuisé
alors je veux juste faire des choses un
petit peu à l'endroit dans le temps est
ce que même si tu es sortie d'à nouveau
avec l'action monsieur théodose mais
nous avons la même famille politique que
nous allons pouvoir depuis longtemps
mais c'est ce que je n'ai pas là je veux
qu'on passe et cela vous avez déjà dit
alors quand vous dites qui alors à
l'opposé les problèmes vous avez posé la
question qu'est ce qu'on dit un jeune
qui veut venir
joli du devenir diable parce qu'il y
aura un changement il y aura une
nouvelle équipe et avec cette nouvelle
équipe loin les gens pour la compagnie
on voit pas sa carte un cabinet d'études
on va avoir au niveau de la mairie
quelqu'un vous occuper pour l'accueil
moi je posais vous mettez vous mettez
tout le monde en a mais là je mets de la
famille politique c'est une chose
je ne fais pas du phénomène chez eux les
mains vides la famille politique c'est
une chose de le laisser parler la
volonté politique c'est autre chose mais
vous êtes je n'avais pas depuis 18 ans
et je les positions la table mais
maintenant depuis 22 ans vous n'avez pas
de volonté de changer la loi
je suis d'accord et je l'exigé été le
premier à le dire en vue de nommer un
monsieur marie jeanne a fait sa part
c'est un new generation nouvelle
rapportée genre vous avez confisquer le
pouvoir
et vous n'avez pas changé de forme
justement chargé justement justement du
jeu nous aider vous allez apporter la
réponse vous êtes à votre quatrième
présentation
donc à cette élection à la première date
de 2001 et depuis 19 ans vous répéter la
même chose la même litanie rien ne bouge
arrière pilot c'est une ville en déclin
vous dites effectivement vous ne cessez
de le dire qu'il faut protéger le mourre
notamment les deux rivières qui borne
effectivement ce bourg il faut c'est le
gros dossier à rivière pilote faut
savoir comment m que dire d'autre
hors d'eau quelles sont les solutions
aujourd'hui de genre son bonhomme qui
visiblement n'a eu de cesse de le
répéter depuis maintenant 19 ans
monsieur monsieur mon avis ai-je besoin
de répondre on va passer à la banque dès
lors que vous avez pour passer la marque
saint martin de ré a ction famille
autoritaire
je dis ce que dit la population
j'ai posé sous la tente évidemment il ya
un contexte politique particulier à gap
lot
je vais vous dire j'étais d'aller
jusqu'au point à dire puisque la
population n'a pas l'air de comprendre
la réalité du d'y faire des propositions
d'alliance avec les élèves allons
travailler ensemble
sauf que le contexte est tel qu'il est
livré avec la tasse en fonctionnement je
suis aujourd'hui en opposition avec le
gîte avec les doigts avec meilleur et
puis avec le mans 6-6 et ce qui a échoué
j'adore je finis laissez moi finir je
vais pour l'avoir déjà fini je dis
simplement c'est vrai qu'un autre bout
notre ville en général a besoin d'un
nouveau souffle a besoin de nouveaux
balles en compagnie ça nous vous parlons
évidemment on ne peut pas le faire seul
on ne décrète pas on ne décrète avec la
population on le découvre en faisant une
démocratie citoyenne en allant à la
rencontre comme il dit les porteurs de
projets en allant à la rencontre des
pères et mères de familles de cette
commune pour les accompagner et leur
permettre de s'intégrer véritablement ya
une cassure entre le bourg où la
périphérie du goût et la campagne notre
ville a implosé
donc moi je suis favorable aujourd'hui à
recréer la cohésion
oui il faut agir si on veut redynamiser
de la ville il faut travailler sous ton
d'où notre slogan est notre projet
s'articule autour d'une idée simple
notre bout et au centre commercial à
partir de cette idée là nous voulons que
ceux que l'on trouve ailleurs on le
trouve dans notre beau pour cela il faut
pas un certain nombre de choses
effectivement il faut accompagner les
porteurs de projets mais je considère
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons urgemment
besoin qu'il y ait une action qui soit
menée parce que vous pouvez valley au
jour
aujourd'hui le tout à l'égout n'est pas
réglée et monsieur le maire devrait
expliquer pourquoi parce qu il a voulu
protéger l'ancienne équipe qui est sorti
qui n'avait pas réglé le problème de
tout à l'égout et il doit gérer le
problème d'un investisseur qui a
construit un immeuble dans la ville pour
laquelle il ne peut pas rentabilisé son
bien parce que la ville n'a pas fait les
efforts et jean giono j'ai fini c'est
moi que je suis aussi têtue vous je fais
nous avons répondu à la question à la
question de l'armement faire pour que la
ville soit au dos et le dossier cet
ancien nageur qui ne relèvent plus
complètement de la compétence de la
ville parce que c'est désormais de la
compétence de la communauté de l'espace
sucre et c'est à partir de là en tant
que maire je convoquerai d'une réunion
entre les cta la collectivité
territoriale de martin qu'elle est
spacieux et ce sera un point de
marchandage avec le nouveau président de
la commune la communauté ou dur nous
voulons faire partie d'une majorité
communautaire ne me suit à la fonction
des attentes et ça à la commission c'est
vrai choix parce qu'il n'a pas
d'autorité et toute nouvelle autorité
il obtient cette dénomination des chats
passage shanxi qui est ce qui est
président c'est son copain alors sur les
copains et qu'on ne verra pas en boîte
le président de la collectivité de la
communauté des spas reçus de la commune
c'est sympa ça j'ai fini sur ce marché
oui j'ai la dernière sortie d'études
précieuses heures après 2008 parce que
j'avais posé sur la table la question de
la mise hors d'eau qui était un mot
peut-être un peu un peu un peu global
parce que tout le monde ne comprend pas
la notion de mise hors d'eau parce que
les gens parce que vous allez arrêter
on ne peut pas je le redis on ne peut
pas se battre contre la nature toutefois
toutefois il ya quand même un certain
nombre de mesures à prendre ne serait-ce
que le curage du bas de la de la rivière
pilote en aval le travail de nettoyage
des berges de rivières alors il monsieur
j'ai bien vu des tracteurs ou des peines
le long le long de la petite fille d'un
pilote
mais ce travail là était insuffisant
puisque nous avons en innovation de les
autres doit primer les actions qui n'ont
pas été suffisants et oui je n'accuse
pas c'est la compétence comprenait
beaucoup sur votre temps mais c'est
vraiment une réponse bien gg
salut beaucoup de choses à monsieur
ghosn a dit vous avez échoué parce que
vous n'avez pas assez d'autorité non non
non c'est sûr comme monsieur bandol dit
je ne lui connais pas celui qui parle le
plus fort qui a raison concernant
concernant il ya pilotes mais je suis
désolé c'est dès le 17 juin 2014
je suis arrivé en avril 2014 et ça parce
que j'ai envoyé un courrier
j'ai envoyé un courrier à hauteur de
l'adn ou deux mois de cure échange un
premier temps et puis j'ai lancé un
programme d'action plein pour les
préventions inondations qui suit son
cours et parce que ce cas oui le papy
c'est quoi le papy si simplement mettre
aussi lui mais l'humain au centre avec
donc des curages qui se font mais pas
seulement le curage et puis à des
endroits
ddd palplanches des bassins de rétention
bien au delà et puis aussi mettre les
leviers des capteurs pourquoi des
capteurs parce que dans ce programme là
c'est faire en sorte que la population
soit quand même averti en cadeau le pape
y sus au collet réunion avec le comité
de pilotage se font avec les commerçants
alors que je vous dise est-ce que ça va
assez vite rejouer j'aurais aimé que ça
aille beaucoup plus vite mais on ne peut
pas me demander d'aller plus vite alors
que dans le temps c'est vrai si un mec
qui était allé régulièrement à côté des
administrés dans la rivière pour que les
choses aillent c'est bien les moto2 et
puis comme je vous ai dit je me suis
heurté à un certain nombre de
difficultés
le divulguer quoi chaque fois que la des
halles
venez curé la rivière on pourrait le
petit poisson le but de lapierre on
avait la police de l'eau les collègues
qui venait qui venait taux qui venaient
les empêcher de faire ce qu elle donc
ses camarades est important en plus de
ça comme ce monopole de copains moi je
suis bien avec tout le monde on nous
coupait tout pas tout bon je sais pas
est contré à la présidence de l'espace
sud
oui président ne laisse pas supposer je
suis ami de tout mais je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas en
politique la politique c'est un débat
d'idées résultat lundi louis régis vous
allez vous allez terminer mais
disciplinés et en plus quand nous avec
mon équipe nous disons des choses nous
allons à l'information
vous savez ici c'est un document papier
en introduction qu'est ce qui est dit je
vous donne lecture 1 et c'est exactement
ce qui figure ce qui est valable pour le
plus noir ou blanc concertation
préalable et la consultation du public
ça veut dire qu'il faut des réunions des
rencontres avec la population
à aucun moment cela n'a été réalisée
c'est une étape obligatoire
réglementaire j'avais un petit peu plus
loin en introduction de première page
enfin c'est ce pacte ne peuvent ses
pattes peuvent s'ils ne sont pas
maîtrisés induire eux mêmes des
désordres sur le territoire susceptible
d'aggraver à terme les risques d ordre
sur les ouvrages et sur d'autres parties
du territoire et puis en fait ils ne
sont pas infaillibles et peuvent être
dépassés par un événement plus important
cela veut dire que effectivement il y à
un papy on nous l'a dit il y en ait plus
on l'a dit ça a été prescrit mais le
plus le papy se trouve à quel stade à
quel niveau les informations que je
possède au stade du diagnostic
alors monsieur veut que monsieur louis
j'ai juste une question avant de passer
la parole à monsieur vladimir meilleur
monsieur vous avez quand même de
nombreuses casquettes
oui vous êtes troisième vice président
de l'assemblée de martinique
vous êtes troisième vice président du
parc national clinique
le quatrième est membre de la commission
agriculture membre de la commission
numérique également la cible est ce que
tenter de vous demander avec toutes ces
casquettes nous aurait pu faire jouer de
vos relations pour faire avancer tous
les dossiers de la commanderie
le sommet de l'iceberg vous me tend une
perche c'est certainement vous savez je
ne suis pas dans le copinage par poste
s'il y avait des projets des dossiers
déposés à la ctm concernant la ville
d'och via pilote c'est avec joie que je
les ai accompagnés
je ne peux pas me substituer à l'équipe
vous voyez ce document je les présentais
ya pas si longtemps que cela
c'est la dernière le rapport 48 de la
plénière du 18 décembre 2019 c'est la
ctc l'aide de la collectivité
territoriale aux communes et rien n'a
abouti
non mais je vous explique ce sont des
aides qui sont attribuées aux communes
et aux pc 10 qui en font la demande
quand il dépose quand elle dépose des
projets c'est noté noir sur blanc sur
l'ensemble des communes seules six
communes je ne suis pas toutes les
communes rivière-pilote n'ont pas
transmis de dossiers alors ça veut dire
qu'il n'y a pas de projet je ne peux pas
me substituer à la municipalité
cependant quand on va plus loin on
constate que ça pète on peut qu'on peut
comprendre que la la la municipalité
n'ait pas les moyens de constituer les
dossiers mais dans les champs
d'application
il y également les études qui sont
proposés par la collectivité et on peut
obtenir des aides jusqu'à 70 % du
plafond
donc s'il y avait effectivement des
projets
je les aurai accompagnés pour la ville
dans l'intérêt de la ville de nice vous
êtes très en retard allez-y alors avant
de commencer j'ai entendu un certain
nombre de choses qui sont qui m'ont un
peu choqué quand même j'ai entendu
parler de confiscation les des élections
par monsieur bonhomme comme s'il y avait
un pilote il n'y a jamais eu de
démocratie avant avant ce jour monsieur
bonhomme a été élu au conseil municipal
il s'est présenté 4 c'est la 4ème fois
que se présente trois fois de suite il a
été élu au conseil municipal me
semble-t-il
donc il ya eu une véritable démocratie
arrive je ne peux pas laisser dire ça ce
soir que je confirme et monsieur que je
confirmais s'imaginera qui a pas de
démocratie je suis l'animateur de
confiscation des élèves jamais dit qu'il
ya pas de démocratie se sont fiancés
mais même à ce que vous avez déjà pas
merci j'ai entendu dire que les permis
de construire sont rejetés parce qu'il
n'ya pas de plus si les permis de
construire sont rejetés c'est parce que
monsieur le maire vous rejette ces
permis construire c'est pas maintenant
monsieur le maire a toujours un avis
favorable je me situe à une volonté
politique d'accompagner les piloter mais
rassurez-vous vous allez on va aller
total si vous valez bons souvenirs
continuent alors concernant
l'aménagement du territoire pour nous il
ya pelote c'est un territoire il faut on
pense pas bourrer campagne plage on a
une vision globale de l'aménagement de
la ville via pilote souffre on va dire
de son éloignement à la rn5 et nous
avons un projet audacieux ambitieux pour
on va dire et tirer le bon le centre
bouvet cette rn 5 903 bout et en dessous
le niveau de la mer on va pas on va pas
se laisser emporter par la rivière
j'entends des choses qui sont
intéressantes mais la rivière c'est du
domaine de l'état de l'espace sud les
inondations ces domaines de l'état de
l'espace sud et c'était 1 sonne ses
véritables responsables doivent à un
moment notre sortir des bois et régler
leurs problèmes
si ce problème à mon avis si ce problème
n'a jusqu'à présent sur ces principes
mais est ce que une municipalité peut
pas mettre la pression entre guillemets
impulsé où est ce que je veux dire
ce geste il faut juste faire attention à
mon avis si le rôle d'une amère et de
s'amuser ça fait c'est comme ça que je
dis que ça serait chargé posé la
question à monsieur meyer est ce que ce
n'est pas le rôle d'une musicalité
je termine travaux la ville il est
facile pour l'état de ne rien faire et
de dire que friedman msv eux n'ont rien
fait à rivière-pilote face et on va y
revenir lundi
on va revenir là dessus oui la mairie
peu le maire peut faire des choses les
barrières anti-inondation ça ces essais
de guérir un cancer avec des pansements
c'est pas ça qui va empêcher les
inondations dans le centre bourg de
rivière-pilote
il faut savoir que cette question ce
serait quoi on est en dessous de le
niveau de la mer au bout et tout les
scientifiques nous disent que le niveau
de la mer ne cesse d'augmenter donc
c'est inéluctable que la rivière entre
dans le bouddha yvias pu alors qu'est ce
que l'état doit prendre ses
responsabilités et que j'appellerais si
ça se passe encore les pilotes à se
mobiliser massivement penser que la
mobilisation se suffit moment là c'est
ce qu'a fait un problème piloter ce sera
pour le martiniquais et vous verrez que
les loups sont yvon dubois pour régler
rapidement ce problème
notre plan d'aménagement nous avons des
grandes zones agricoles à rivière-pilote
de grandes zones touristiques des zones
commerciales centre bourg nous avons
avec ses 6 no 2 rue qu'on connaît qui
typiquement mannequin ou caribéens
nous avons nos quartiers d'été de la
campagne de l'ariège campagne avec des
noms l'âge au sol a sonné mon escape
c'est pas des noms qui sont tirés au
hasard nous avons une vision de
l'aménagement global de la ville de
rivière pilote et nous poser présentant
ce projet audacieux ambitieux pilotait
alors nous passons donc à deuxième
thématique puisque nous avons entamé la
seconde moitié de ce débat consacré à la
ville de rivière pilote je vous le
rappelle avec 5 candidats donc autour de
la table jean françois bonhomme denis
nous régissent edouard marrant raymond
théodose et victor vladimir veilleurs
donc à nous allons parler de la
politique sociale éducative et et
culturel qu'est ce que vous entendez
proposé pour la prochaine mandature donc
aux administrés concernant donc l'offre
notamment donc d'activités culturelles
sportives on a entendu aussi dans le
micro trottoir quelques habitants se
plaindre d'un dolman d'activités
notamment aussi évoqué le stade de
rivière pilote et pourtant il ya pilotes
on le sait c'est un club de football
fameux le rc rivière pilote voilà donc
nous allons
commencez par vous jean françois
bonhomme de ce point de vue là qu'est ce
que vous avez concocté
je ne pouvais là je me parle de la
réalité je pars de la réalité de deux
guides capitale nous avons une ville qui
a un passé sportif glorieux nous avons
un certain nombre de sportifs dans la
ville nous avons aujourd'hui une ville
qui est en souffrance
ce n'est pas la faute du maire tu es
simplement qu'ils manquent de vision
autour du sport je veux faire du sport
le deuxième pôle de l'action éducative
dans cette ville aux côtés de l'école
comment je veux que les clubs sportifs
et de l'élection nous désignerons un
délégué aux sports
tu a pour mission de réunir tous les
présidents de clubs pour fixer avec des
objectifs clairs et un programme
d'accompagnement pour prendre les gamins
du plus jeune âge ça veut dire que vous
allez fléché des moyens budgétaires pour
sa réaction si nous allons prendre sur
certains postes sur pour cette quasi
désertique longue barbe que nous le
fassions pourquoi parce que c'est ce que
j'attends c'est quand même là la
conséquence c'est quoi monsieur
la conséquence est que vous avez des
jeunes qui souvent décrochent des jeunes
qui sont pas intégrés donc je voudrais
qu'on les prenne en charge qu'il soit
accompagné du plus jeune âge jusqu'au
troisième âge qu'on les accompagne tout
le monde soit dans une dynamique
sportive c'est une priorité puisque la
priorité pour la vie budget doit venir
du tout l'éclat sportif algérien moyens
budgétaires
je ne veux plus comme les clubs sportifs
tire la langue ni eau ni rooney ni au
basket
je veux que les clubs ouais une ville
comme dirait pilote aujourd'hui doit
être ou au firmament de l'athlétisme
nous devons revenir à ce niveau là et je
mets un engagement c'est que dans dans
dans moins de trois ans nous aurons un
club la tétine de haut niveau je le dis
bien et deuxième élément c'est annoncé
depuis 23 ans
nous avons un engagement majeur et ce
sera probablement le seul investissement
majeur que nous ferons sous la mandature
c'est la création de au respect des
lignes de ce nom à la hauteur de nos
ambitions et la hauteur de notre
personnalité
croyez moi je me battrai et si je le dis
bien j'irai à la rencontre des
présidents de tout déléguer le tout
génial en compte
les élus de président tous produits
voilà monia ville qui cache en fait
comme on dit un citoyen di cicco réuni
nos pagnes a recueilli citoyens alors
mon lycée polyvalent sportifs et de
sécurité pour révéler plus merci
monsieur le maire sortant alors monsieur
monsieur le bruit mais ce qu'il va faire
mais moi j'ai déjà vous aviez déjà j'ai
dit ouais très prochainement monsieur
paul yao n'dre oui non non non toutes
les bêtises et j'aime mon coin que pour
le hand et le et le basque ou au niveau
du stade omnisport 11 oui mais non on
fait du yoyo à lui qu'est ce que c'est
c'est toujours ce qui se joue en dix
éditions
tous ces parcours 21,2 alors il ya deux
choses qu'on croit qu'on fera puisque
c'est au fur à mesure vous pensez que ce
dieu coup de baguette magique qu'on peut
tout faire et puis je me suis enfoncé
non monsieur
par contre là je voulais je faisais peu
quand même partie de l'équipe de
monsieur vo
j'étais aussi animé je crois que je sais
quand même tous d'où je viens je sais
quand même 12 janvier c'est à ce niveau
les épaules de difficultés mais comme je
vous ai dit oui ce rôle ce rôle avec les
poules basque est peut être petit mais
ça qu'il faut voir
nous avons compté nous avons porté une
amie l'audition sûr sinon non
véritable ambition ambition nous nous
avons pomme c nous avons compté aussi
natation particulière sur le le stade en
cas mais qui était vraiment à mes depuis
digne ça nous a fait quand même plus
d'un million d'euros la roupie l'excité
mais on ne peut pas tout faire de coup
de baguette magique
il ya aussi la la la piste athétisme
même monsieur mot lol j'ai remis un
dossier
ce jour là ça peut ça peut se retrouver
à l'ancien ministre laura flessel et
c'est ce que je voulais qu'ils
aboutissent
mais ce qui s'est passé de toi joue
après là il ya eu elle a démissionné
mais ça n'empêche que nous avons la
volonté de le relancer mais ça n'est pas
simplement parce qu'ils sont dans la
même mouvance c'est pas cher bonhomie la
même mouvance on pensait à la halle à la
piste nous mais finalement ça n'a pas
abouti mais l'autre l'autre l'autre
sujet que nous allons aborder c'est le
bout parce que au départ il était prévu
de recouvrir le tirer du groupe la
difficulté c'est que nous sommes quand
même si hélas on ne sait quel type de
masque est inattendu elle doit on pas
dit mot parole de m
nous avons notre grand regret
oui mais non n'empêche que cette
solution là n'est pas perdu parce que
effectivement
effectivement lorsque nous avons voulu
faire soviétique en 2014 nous nous pas
de l'eau c'est pas on ne se cache pas
des lots mais il faut quand même ce sont
des données vu qu'il faut quand même
poêle de certaines précautions mais
fofolle tout ça nous avons effectivement
continuer ce jeu
solide et tout mais c'est ça qui est oui
tout à fait ce qu'il ya aussi c'est
qu'on voyait aussi le titre du groupe
pour de manière à ce que les jeunes
puissent être la sécurité d'autant plus
que ça crée aussi ça crée aussi une
seule des deux nations merci je me
souviens monsieur marrant mais c'est
marrant une ville qui perd près de 800 1
900 habitants en cinq ans signe
effectivement de l'affaiblissement total
de cette ville alors quelle politique
réelle pour attirer les champs en
matière d'attractivité bien sûr en
matière sociale et culturelle
effectivement pour que les gens puissent
rester arrivé à kehl qu'est ce que vous
allez faire si je suis élu maire d'ici
le 22 mars
ceci étant dit en matière de diminution
de population
faut dire aussi que nous ne sommes pas
les seuls concernés
pratiquement toutes les villes même les
grandes villes perdent beaucoup de ses
habitants
et puis on a un exode comment ça allait
comment génocide
oui il ya ceux de she's not there
expliquer toute substitution qui est en
cours qui ne finit pas de ne pas finir
donc il ya tout ça et les jeunes cet
esthète parti et ne reviennent pas je ne
sais pas si vous savez le nombre de
maisons abandonnées des familles qu'ils
aux enfants sont partis ils font tout
pour aller rejoindre nos enfants pour
s'occuper des petits enfants très bien
après le constat qu'est ce que vous
faites de la mla maintenant que vous
avez ça bien alors il y a pour redonner
de la vie à la vie c'est au nombre
d'actions il n'y a pas une mais ya
plusieurs banques totale là j'ai parlé
des commerçants qu'il faut encourager à
revoir à mettre en oeuvre attirer les
gens à penser d'action ensuite vous avez
ensuite allure mais là on est sur
l'offre est riche et bien j'arrive
j adore on s'affole je crois qu'il faut
rénover complètement la formule d'une
culture elle revoit sa complètement de
fond en comble j'ai connu que ce soit le
début pourquoi est-ce que ça n'attire
plus c'est sa main une fête de quartier
n'ont pas ça il faut il faut préciser
moi tout affolement je ne m'affole pas
mes deux d'école ma part je l'espère
dans sa nasse au plus et c'est ça le
problème en a six ou plus les dicussions
immense mais depuis l'accident victime
finissant à 10 ou plus c'est ça le drame
étant donné les échanges que sur elle
même et j'avais dû me dit tu es jeune tu
n'as pas la porte s'il te plaît c'est
pas d'histoire celle là j'ai dit que
c'est pourquoi pourquoi les nuits
culturelles n'attire plus parce que le
le le prestige mais oui le programme le
contenu ça n'attire pas une mutuelle
thérèse on était go on et jaeglé
pratiquement toutes les associations et
c'est là ce sera un des points forts de
mon programme
la vie associative il faut il faut
donner les moyens aux associations
ce que c est le coeur des quartiers le
coeur de la ville les aider mais je dis
toujours dans toutes les réunions que
j'ai fait ce cas prison que les
associations je suis prêt à travailler
avec je veux aussi encourager à
travailler alors ce sera un contrat avec
eux ce que vous proposez
ce que la municipalité va faire pour
vous accompagner
et puis à la fin on va faire un bilan ce
qui a marché ce qui a moins marché tout
là toutes les associations sportives
culturelles et cetera et cetera puisque
il est temps que les associations de
commerçants tous ces gens là il faudra
travers avec ya également comment non
non mais ce soit fini comme celui-là
hu a dynamisé la fois agricole qui est
en train
dégringolait qui n'a plus le prestige
qu'il avait avant on a été la première
commune à avoir un visa c'était un vieux
pilote est maintenant effectivement tout
le monde a repris
donc il va falloir a perdue puisqu'on
n'a pas innové
on n'a pas apporté quelque chose en plus
il faut intégrer davantage
d'institutions d'un viable et c'est que
les jeunes merci intégrer les écoles s
est il ya beaucoup de classe et on
aurait plutôt paroles pourraient même
pas conclure si vous avez épuisé
les autres vont faire leurs comptes oui
j'ai fait tellement de choses à dire
grand-chose à faire voilà données du
registre très bien merci
je crois que le véritable changement
c'est en mettant du sparadrap sur
l'existant non il faut mettre un vrai
coup de pied dans la fourmilière
la première chose que nous allons faire
c'est d'aller à la rencontre de tous les
partenaires
aujourd'hui tout ce qui ce fait se fait
sur les fonds propres de la commune
ce n'est pas normal quand nous payons
des impôts sur la petite case ouvre
droit aux exonérations
il n'est pas porté si vous habitez
rivière l'autre cochet vous serez
exonéré
non vous payez comme tout le monde donc
il faut aller chercher les fonds d'état
les fonds de l'uaw la ctm tous ceux qui
peuvent accompagner la collectivité
municipale dans ses projets et pour cela
la première chose que nous allons ferme
et je l' ai déjà dit et je le répète
nous ferons un audit organisationnel
ce qui permettra de connaître les
capacités et ce que fait chaque personne
dans la collectivité valoriser le
personnel en quoi faisant
en lui permettant de se former si le
ciel s'ils le souhaitent ou encore si le
besoin se faisait sentir
mais il faudra aussi d'avoir à avoir du
personnel en catégorie à
parce qu'il faudra que ce personnel soit
opérationnel pour que nous puissions
pour permettre à nos dossiers de voir
nos projets de voir le jour alors on me
dira oui mais c'est la fuite vers eux
l'explosion du budget de fonctionnement
non comment nous allons faire comment
nous allons pallier à cela nous avons
fait exactement ce qui se fait ailleurs
oui bien salée par exemple à diminuer sa
facture d'éclairage de 50 % celle du
fonctionnement
en quoi faisant remplaçants ces ampoules
conventionnelles par des ampoules led 50
% sur la facture d'électricité
et ben voilà comment nous allons pas
liée à l' embauche de personnels de
catégorie et ce personnel de catégorie a
ou le personnel actuellement présents
qui mérite d'être valorisé sera
opérationnel justement pour répondre aux
besoins de nos projets merci de suivre
vos religieuse pour l'institution de
lézinnes le personnel et pavane weezy
très bien ça le sinon je ne peux pas
arriver métier c'est impersonnel que
d'aider notre arrivée un personnel qui
accompagné avec des formations et je
suis fier de personnes dessus de ses
personnels là il faut et l'exemple que
je prends l'exemple de paul c'est
l'exemple du 31 octobre où tout ce
personnel assez mis à la disposition de
la ville c'est ce qui est important mais
je dis que le cas le personnel soit bien
ils sont bien dans leur tête
assurez-vous en tout cas rien monsieur
monsieur maintenant la 2cv je répondais
à quelques termes été dure pour les
questions me suis mis l'accent notamment
sur le manque d'imagination total de
l'équipe en place je suis pas vous avez
des projets plein la tête en matière de
politique sociale et culturelle pour
redynamiser votre ville j'ai fait quand
même répondre à ce que j'ai entendu
vous parlez de jeunes qui voulaient
venir s'installer à rivière-pilote nous
n'allons pas faire appel à un cabinet
d'audit l'espace et d'incompétence à des
personnes qualifiées formé pour
accompagner les jeunes créateurs
d'entreprise notamment et nous allons
nous appuyer sur l'espace sud parce que
j'ai une commune c'est j'irai aussi avec
ses partenaires notamment l'espace sud
qui est un partenaire privilégié nous
allons mettre à la mairie de rivière
pilote un bureau ou qui accompagnera six
jeunes créateurs d'entreprise les jeunes
ont besoin
à rivière-pilote de se sentir bien dans
leur ville pour se sentir bien il faut
parfois y travailler mais en tout cas
trouvé un certain non
activités de restauration d'amusement et
autres pour pouvoir s'épanouir dans sa
ville et les jeunes ont besoin de
s'épanouir arrivé au pilote ce n'est pas
le cas actuellement
j'ai entendu parler aussi d'une piste
d'athlétisme qui parle et novaes parce
que le ministre a été limogé c'est quand
même triste d'entendre ça donc ce sont
les ministres français maintenant qui
décide des besoins de la pop c'est ce
qu'on a tous compris qu elle qui décide
des besoins de la population de la
pelote en 10 2010 est monsieur le maire
a demandé dans le cadre de l'aide aux
communes c'est comme 7000 euros à la
septième en 2019 rien du tout pourquoi
ils n'ont rien n'a rien demandé pour
offrir cette piste d'athlétisme
monsieur le maire oui là il a monté le
toit la toiture du stade alfred mylne
c'est bien merci monsieur le maire
c'était utile
monsieur le maire à réparer des routes
communales ont mis c'est bien c'est
utile merci monsieur le maire mais ce
que ces seuls à avoir une vision pour le
développement de sa commune c'est la
question où sont les véritables projets
canton tout le monde parle de stade
omnisports qui peuvent servir à
plusieurs sports mais notamment si pour
des concerts des spectacles et les
choses de ce genre
monsieur le maire pas de couvrir un
stade qui a derrière le stade de
handball qui a derrière le stade est
votre petit bois il nous faut un
véritable hall omnisports à l'image de
la ville de rivière pilote à l'image des
sportifs piloter dans la sachez quand
même que c'est de la compétence de
l'espace sud il y avait des chocs dont à
deux élus de la mairie fut l'auteur
bureau de l'espace sud oui dites nous
quel est votre cas
ça laisse pas cher faut accuser je ne
sais pas fini de digérer c'est tout le
monde parlait jusqu'à présent mais aussi
à venir jusqu'en mai non je voudrais
jamais demandé si on est comme ça
en face seul à l'essai monsieur chez la
mère a trouvé en arrivant en excès de
quasiment 9 millions d'euros à la mairie
devient claude c'est pas lui qui l'aida
qu il les a trouvés en arrivant on peut
se demander qu'est ce qu'il en a fait
puisque il finit avec 9 millions d'euros
à l'époque
la bonne gestion c'est faire beaucoup
avec peu
monsieur le maire a fait peu avec
beaucoup alors monsieur lorsqu'on
parce qu'on commence vous concernant si
vous voulez concernant la politique
sociale culturelle sportive
nous mettrons les associations sportives
culturelles sociales toutes les asociaux
ne vient plus être au coeur de la ville
d'un viol est de 10 ans finalement non
mais nous ne nous pénalise
nous le ferons nous nous appuyons sur
les associations et nous les aiderons
nous accompagnons parce que aussi à
l'amérique vie au pilote il ya un bureau
pour accompagner les associations que ce
soit pour la fonction ou oralement ou
par part des subsides de dvd d'avoir des
activités de pâques si possible avec des
subventions au fonctionnement des
associations
mais les aider à aller chercher aussi
des subventions que ce soit et à leroy
ou autre pour le fonctionnement et les
événements qui vont créer arrivé au
pilote mais je vais dire deux mots quand
même sous les associations et notamment
celles qui s'occupent des plus jeunes
arrivés au pilote les associations
sportives et culturelles oui elles vont
former on va prendre l'exemple du du
dispo du football on peut former des
futurs qu'il y en ait mbappé ou autres
dom est-ce que c'est cela vraiment
l'essentiel
ces associations ont besoin d'éducateurs
formés là aussi nous allons les
accompagner au travers de ce bureau pour
formuler de leurs éducateurs parce qu'on
a besoin ils vont former les citoyens de
demain les médecins les carreleurs les
mécaniciens de mai les maires de demain
les hommes politiques de demain
donc on a besoin de véritables jeunes
équilibre et épanouie et militants
formés à yopougon je revenais parce que
c'est plus de 600000 euros quand même
que la ville
mais jacques et la vie accompagne et
aide monsieur v mon association
nous sommes là
maintenant il faut structurer à des
associations il faut aussi savoir pour
faire notre programme fédérer les
énergies sas offriez ses fédérations des
associations
or pour qu'un taux pratique quand il est
à michelin programme qu'on puisse pour
que toute la commune du nord au sud et
laisse à l'ouest puissent bénéficier que
tout le monde soit au courant de ça
qu'il faut dans les parages et donc nous
devons aborder une autre thématique donc
si vous intervenez maintenant on vous
laisse la parole à monsieur bonhomme est
à vous monsieur régis mais soyez court
vraiment un quelques phrases
sinon vous avez puisé votre temps de
parole et vous pourrez plus parler vers
la fin de mission jean françois bonhomme
mais non moi je veux dire simplement si
j'étais con et servira à là c'était à
multiples responsabilités si j'avais
comme certains copains tentant un parent
qui était en responsabilité à 7 m
de la même manière qu'on dépense en un
clin d'oeil 40 millions pour faire le
pont de gagnerons j'aurais déjà essayé
au moins d'obtenir quelques
investissements de la commune voilà
c'est ça que je veux dire donnez-vous
régis juste cozian à la vie à l'espace
et notamment la mission locale du sud
il n'y a aucun chargé de mission qu'ils
soient là pour accompagner les porteurs
de projets la compétence de la mission
locale aux élèves des jeunes de 16 à 25
ans et nous ce que nous disons nous
allons mettre en place un véritable
service des sessions qui aura pour
partenaire privilégié le pôle emploi et
qui pourra répondre un certain nombre de
besoins
pourquoi parce que vous avez les
chiffres certainement vous avez rappelé
11900 habitants vous avez deux sens très
jeune à peu près en situation de chômage
mais vous avez également 721 seniors
donc c'est à nous pas convaincu pdo la
mission locale les jeunes de 7 sur les
213 jeune relève de la mission locale
mais les 700 seniors aux élèves de la
miss du service d'insertion que nous
allons m et puis autre chose que je
voulais dire puisque une asus ne s'agit
pas de parler voiliers géants mec
le schéma de cohérence territoriale se
soit beaucoup de documents mais oui
parce que il s'agit pas de s'agiter de
parler il faut venir avec des éléments
concrets pour expliquer
la population de quoi il s'agit monsieur
le scot vous l'avez le schéma de
cohérence territoriale je vais à la page
30 que j'avais dit faire courant mais
c'est très court je vais la page 32
on parle d orientation c'est à dire tout
ce qui est des prévu pour toutes les
communes du sud
les douze rivière pilote ah oui il y en
a tant bois mais qui était un projet de
l'ancien maire et qui a été motivée par
la volonté du 10 mai accueil qui non
content but en bois que vais encore
quand monsieur là aussi de l'espace et
d'anomalies qui voulait faire et
économique disciplinaire nationale s'est
étonné de ce que nous avons de temps qui
nous reste
si aujourd'hui s'exprime n'existe pas
c'est de la seule volonté de monsieur le
maire qui quand monsieur larcher a
demandé qui était le cas où annoncé
alors pour dire que des économies à
l'espace et de monsieur le maire a levé
le doigt elle a dit moi je renonce à mon
hall des sports en bois nous je pense
que ce n'est pas ça n'est ce pas ça
c'est toi qui le dit c'est vrai qu'au
départ à voir c'est un projet municipal
effectivement avec il est donc passé à
un projet un projet communautaire
communautaire et ce projet qui stagnait
ça sans date pas de sa date du début de
mandature de 2,2 me suivez et quand je
suis arrivé effectivement je crois que
cet espace-là sera utilisé
vraisemblablement pour d'autres projets
alors messieurs mais sur le fond les
yeux un peu de discipline nous reste
qu'à peine 15 minutes d'émission nous
avons encore des thèmes ensemble abordés
nous allons entamer tout de suite ce
troisième thème comment faire pour se
démarquer des autres villes notamment la
ville de sète luce et du marin comment
faire également pour être un véritable
atout incontournable au sein de l'espace
sud la question vous est posée à tous
quelles sont vos priorités en la matière
pour redonner une nouvelle dimension à
rivière-pilote s'intéressent pas sud au
sein de l'espace édouard marrant donc la
place de la ville le travail avec
l'espace sud et comment rivière pilote
peut se développer notamment en terme de
tourisme c'est un peu gros c'est ce
qu'ils disaient entre le marin qui fait
le choix de la plaisance et becky bon
voilà ça marche
et puis sainte luce qui a fait qu à tous
ses hôtels ses animations
exister ces animations dès le jeudi soir
dans le nord est est ce que vous allez
faire
et alors l'attractivité touristique de
rivière-pilote ça passe par quoi selon
si vous seriez vert il faut une volonté
politique
cette volonté s'est arrêtée en 2014
malheureusement donc il faudra reprendre
tout ça c'est vrai sainte-luce sommes
pris entre lui sainte lucie le mariage
avait concrètement ça passe par quoi que
vous pouvez nous donner un ou deux
exemples de ce qui va me faire selon
vous pour que justement il veut plus
notre part on n'a pas le temps
développer complètement réouvert l'autre
a une histoire riche et autour de ça je
crois que les les colons à l'époque ont
fait leur richesse sur sur la sueur des
esclaves
il faut que les descendants fasse
connaître cette histoire pour
aujourd'hui pour pour donner envie aux
gens de venir inscrire ya beaucoup de
touristes qui viennent avec les pilotes
du brochet ce parce qu'il y avait
l'autre surnom vient placer une histoire
ces boues 310 etc
c'est un nom donc on a d'autres espaces
qu'il faut qu'il faut mettre en valeur
on a des points panoramique
extraordinaire des emplois quoi pourquoi
comment quel site
oui mon allée cite par exemple contre
voie inverse petit coton un petit
couteau et en europe il ya une juste
plan dit de la qui s'est passé à iasi
rien non il ya également le quartier
marie noir
il ya beaucoup de gîtes il ya beaucoup
de chutes là et il ya un inconvénient
majeur effectivement qu'on a rencontrés
quand je suis allé voir la population
s'écria un bruit infernal par exemple
avec le centre de tir qui est presque en
contrebas donc il ya même eu il ya fe y
avoir des gros accident il ya pu y avoir
4 9 et y avait des gens failli perdre la
vie à une dame qui me racontait que
pendant quelle baguette ben ali est chez
elle son tableau qui tu as couché
municipal
je suis motivé il faut il faut
intervenir auprès de l'ue centre de tir
pour les amener à plus de sécurité
c'est fait c'est fait c'est parce qu'ils
ne m'ont dit non mais c'est pas sûr si
des gens il ya vu des gens voulaient
envoyer maintenant mais j'apporte cette
précision
j'ai rencontré des gens accrochés marée
noire jusqu'aux fourmanoir la famille
kabyle affamés oui tous ces gens là sont
venus me voir ils ont fait les
discussions qu est ce qu ils ont fait
une pétition en juillet on va tous j'ai
même envoyé quelques temps ils
m'appellent prenant qui le veut le droit
une balle passée sous son bras mais
sécurisé je ne dis pas qu'il faut
arrêter sécurisé bien la démarche qu'il
faut c'est les autres et pour la
démarche a été faite j'ai reçu ce groupe
de dames d'administrer et j'ai adressé
un courrier à monsieur le préfet est
aussi un courrier à accepte présidente
de du tcsp et effectivement il ya une
amélioration tcp mais c'est sûr que
c'est une problématique a été prise en
compte j'ai adressé un courrier à
monsieur le préfet et la c4 tandis
qu'elle est partie mais nous allons
continuer ou non il
son point fort mais j'ai essayé ça te
gêne était le coach je pouvais quand tu
veux te montrer ses jambes en sécurité
sur notre thème donc relancé par pedro
minervino est assez marrant je constate
vous êtes écarter totalement de ce thème
donc je donne la parole littéralement ne
se donnent pas la question je sais
jamais comment faire pour que l'habile
reviendront puisse exister au sein de
l'espace sud puis se démarquer puisse
avoir sa singularité au sein de l'espace
sud caisse quelles sont vos propositions
en la matière il ya d'abord au sein de
l'espace sud à faire sur le plan
institutionnel il y aura une
représentation de la ville avec beaucoup
de percussions beaucoup de pertinence
beaucoup d'efficacité deuxième élément
ma ville n'est pas quand même là là là -
la moins dotée
j'ai un territoire qui a des atouts
touristiques des atouts géographiques
ça tue c'est à côté je veux bien qu'ils
étaient encore en vie à sainte luce mais
je souhaite que le touriste ou sur la
même chose maintenant je souhaite que
les touristes sort de sainte luce est
venu manger à poirier
venez moi j'ai un blanc fatigue est
venue profiter de ma ville ou à monter
la danse l'agonie des pilotes jusqu'au à
à côté de la cabane des pêcheurs
profiter de quelque chose qui soit
authentique compagnie je ne veux pas
seulement qu'on aille à l'harmonie je
veux qu'on traverse la ville et qu'on y
reste donner de l'éclat mon église
donner de l'éclat au marché comment
comment simplement les effets se font
d'abord il faut des méthodes il faut
d'abord faire savoir
aujourd'hui on est inexistant dans la
communication c'est pas ça fond ne
pouviez pas à pau c'est m soit à tous
parce que nous nous mâche dit celui qui
parle parce que j'ai entendu des gens
parler d'emploi je suis un porteur d'un
certain nombre de choses dont je ne
parle pas de sujet pas d'or mais je dis
simplement si nous voulons véritablement
donner un élan j'allais dire par là
cette ville il faut que nous ayons la
force de porter au devant des touristes
qui viennent ce que nous avons là moni
accompagné au tout et je finis mon
caddie simplement
la vallée de l'harmonie depuis la
concorde où vous avez un site
touristique vous avez la palmeraie des
pastels vous avez là l'usiné et vous
avez le saut qui coule au dessus pas et
vous êtes amusé appel laissez moi donc
pas en même temps avance ben non pas
tant pis vous avez vous avez vous avez
quoi gaudet nous avons tous un godet de
mettre en valeur
vous l'avez pas faire le catalogue jean
françois bonhomme donc peut-être vous
passer la parole à enfin pas si la
parole monsieur louis régis question des
premiers en matière d'association depuis
plus de vingt ans de façon continue et
je suis président d'association et j'ai
prouvé ce que je pouvais faire dans ce
domaine
donc je vais pas revenir là dessus
cependant la question du tourisme
moi je répète tout le temps ces machines
café chez sony en mike leake a cessé de
butch hennouni
il faut fixer le twist à rivière-pilote
je ne dis pas qu'on n'a pas besoin de
ces grands blancs mais le plus souvent
ceux qui travaillent dans ces grands
blocs ne peuvent pas ne pas fixer un
avenir et souvent ce sont des blocs qui
sont construits par défiscalisation et
comme par hasard à la fin de la
défiscalisation est lié à des problèmes
nous ce que nous disons que nous allons
développer les grosses autos illégaux
hôtel il s'agit de cela donc aux
personnes
par contre ce que nous disons il faut
que carrie vie au pilote
tous ceux qui ont cette possibilité
puisse en faire un complément de revenu
ou créer son activité
en quoi faisant en accueillant le
touriste à domicile qu'est ce qui va se
passer à ce moment celui qui va
accueillir le twist à domicile il aura
besoin de l'accueillir dans de bonnes
conditions
il y avoir le maçon de rivière-pilote
l'électricien d'origine le plombier de
rivière-pilote la marchande de légumes
de rivière-pilote il va donner aux
touristes à manger manger paya et c'est
ce qui est important est à ce moment
l'argent reste dans le pays et ça reste
dans la proximité même de la population
tandis que dans les grands blocs l'agent
david batty
il n'y a rien et york aucune retombée et
puisqu'il faut comprendre que nous nous
avons un projet qui mûrement réfléchie
on a parlé des nues culturelles tout à
l'heure nous allons parler d'un
véritable festival international et
croyez moi c'est pas parole en laye nous
savons comment le réaliser et où aller
chercher les fonds nous n'allons pas
faire tout sur le contrefort victoire
vladimir veilleurs sur cet aspect et
puis en conclusion sur la politique
touristique pour nous tous pas du
rond-point de poirier où nous devons
avoir un point d'information touristique
pour capter les centaines de milliers de
martiniquais de touristes qui en pointe
c'est tout qui vont directement dans
dans dans le grand sud
nous ne pouvons pas rivaliser avec
sainte luce sur le banner les hôtels
nous cherchons pas à rivaliser nous ne
pouvons pas rivaliser que le marin sur
la plaisance nous n'allons pas chercher
à rivaliser que ce que nous voulons
c'est capter les touristes que ça soit à
sainte luce ou même depuis la france où
douze joqueviel et développé à
rivière-pilote notamment l'arrière-pays
monsieur marc en parler d'aider des
auteurs mais si bien il a écouté mes
interventions
il faut aider à piloter riche de passe
qui moi aussi géographique de ces
personnes de ses habitants impact man
une culture et le patrimoine historique
et nous mettrons des points de vue dans
les hauteurs de rivia place parce que
nous voulons que les touristes avaient
aussi en profondeur dans la ville samedi
dernier j'étais au bout de vie est
plutôt tour du marché et j'ai vu des
centaines de tous ces dix cité des
fourmis folky quart pour mener là ils
sont trop chaud qui passe sous le choc
y a personne pour les accompagner et à
personne pour leur expliquer le nom des
rues dont il vient pleuvent pour leur
faire visiter notre église du centre
books a une histoire il ya personne qui
pour les emmener dans l'arrière-pays
pilotin sens il faudrait mettre ce genre
de plat ça il faudrait une véritable
politique touristique avia pelote avec
des personnes formées à hilton à des
artisans magnifique dans l'arrière-pays
des agriculteurs à voir des artisans
toutes sortes de choses et nous comptons
mais tous ces atouts la en valeur pour
développer le
le développement touristique arrive il
rappelle que ça se fait en partenariat
avec la communauté d'agglomération qui
est en fait la ville n'est pas exclu une
hausse de compétence générale
quand on jette à volonté on fait des
choses raymond théodose rapidement sur
un fil et sa volonté elle est là puisque
je vous signale qu'au début d'année j'ai
pas eu deux fleuves pilote effectivement
qu'est entre-temps avec la gema pis il
s'y passe est donc vraiment au niveau de
la compétence de l'espace une mais nous
allons continuer à faire le sol que ce
projet n'aboutisse
on ne peut pas d'un coup de baguette
magique rapidement comme ça fait en
sorte que le jeu avance c'était un
projet autant autant que j'ai pu avoir
la main sur le pauvre de la réduction
dam d'augy pas de la sécurité des
pilotes et mais eux au moins que suffit
le pilote
je n'ai pas tout à fait la même si
j'avais eu la messe la réduction la lame
d'eau ça n'a pas été si tu vas pas
donner des notions aussi
la voix a apporté bien même un projet
d'activité forte sur la rivière et c'est
pas de sa foi mais bon j'ai pas vu le
jour on va pas tous voulaient tous très
bien voilà nous passons donc aux
conclusions
le tirage au sort a désigné raymond
théodose pour terminer cet exercice
donc nous allons commencer par edouard
marrant vous avez une minute une minute
pour conclure oui après on nous ont
choisi simplement le tirage au sort des
ateliers le dernier celui qui termine
les conclusions
oui qui termine donc allez-y et loire
marrant en une minute vous adresser
directement aux électrices et électeurs
de rivière pilote à dire qu'ils nous
écoutent en tout cas ben population de
les régler à belhadj nom venant avec une
équipe nouvelle équipe et nous voulons
faire changer les choses
il ya des sujets qu'on n'a même pas le
temps d'aborder comme les personnes
âgées
on n'a pas eu le temps d'aborder ce
sujet les associations qui sont tous
blessés ces personnes âgées
on n'a pas eu le temps de les aborder et
d'autres pleins sujet encore là je vous
assure pas mais vous auriez pu vous avez
votre temps de parole mais il y avait
abordé ce sujet vous mais oui mais
loisir d'entendre ce contenu univar oui
alors allez-y doucement
donc j'en appelle à la population à
ouvrir les yeux à voir vraiment le
candidat qu'ils le paraissent le plus
crédible le plus sérieux le plu est
disposée est capable de mener à bien les
projets pour rivière-pilote c'est nous
entrons dans le rang dans un moment
crucial pour rivière-pilote son émission
on rate ce qu'une minute si on rate ses
finitions race la prochaine mandature
jeu sera très gras faux nom au machin
moment où l'on parle qu'on l'a dit tout
à l'heure
cinq russes en train de dépasser et le
marin en train de prendre de l'ampleur
il faut que rivière l'autre se réveille
il faut du but
marama des autres les bélougas
mais l'un est blanc six pays doit marc
messier victor gradimir veille n'ont pas
la parole en dernier cette fois si vous
avez des fois ça peut être un avantage à
tous les autres développer leurs
arguments
et puis le 2020 ne s'agit pas de
remplacer un participant nous nous avons
un véritable projet ambitieux audacieux
pour le développement économique de la
ville de rivière-pilote vive la boîte
une ville inclusive où tous les pilotins
trouvent leur place comme je l ai dit
allez nous allons nous appuyer sur les
associations notamment pour mettre en
place cette politique culturelle
sportive économique s'occuper des
personnes âgées de la petite enfance
à rivière-pilote monsieur le maire a
failli y naïna il n'a pas de projet ils
n'en avaient pas il n'en a pas nous
sommes allés dans des quartiers certains
ne connaissaient même pas le nom du
maire de rivière pilote
je vais demander au pilotage je leur
demande même d'aller écouter les autres
candidats ce qu'ils ont à dire et il
s'en rendront compte que nous avons le
meilleur projet pour la ville de pelote
nous ne pouvons pas hypothéquer l'avenir
notamment de la jeunesse pilotine en
faisant les mêmes erreurs et en
s'attendant à un résultat différent donc
le 15 nov
je vais demander au pilote n se
mobiliser massivement et de voter pour
la liste unités piétinent avec vito
vladimir à sa tête merci monsieur meyer
jean françois bonhomme pour la
conclusion de ce soir piétine
chers compatriotes vous me connaissez je
suis fidèle à lever à piloter je suis
passionné par cette ville je suis
extrêmement malheureux de voir notre
ville en déclin j'arrive avec une équipe
jeune dynamique volontaire pour donner
un véritable bal aura cette ville
prendre en charge davantage accompagner
la petite enfance basculer dans la
transition écologique et faire en sorte
qu'ils aient une place pour chacun
sur le plan social sur le plan culturel
faire en sorte que nos villes notre
ville soit rayonnante notre ville soit
forte
notre ville sera belle pour que cela
arrive il faut voter agir pour
rivière-pilote avec jean françois busnel
la seule liste qui pour le changement
politique
avec aplomb votre conclusion denis louis
régis merci alors durant tout ce débat
et je m'adresse aux pilotes et aux
pilotes 1 j'étais le seul le seul à
démontrer concrètement les insuffisances
et en expliquant comment nous pouvons
pas lier à tout cela en apportant les
preuves quand disney expliquant comment
l'équipe en place n'avait aucun projet
il nous faut sortir de cette manière
d'exercer le pouvoir
il nous faut sortir de cette méthode de
fonctionnement qui consiste à venir
taper sur le dos des électeurs à la
veille des élections
et puis à près de disparaître nous ce
que nous disons c'est qu'une fois en
place
nous allons prendre rendez vous avec
vous tous les six mois par des réunions
de karachi pour échanger avec la
population et pour entendre vous souhait
et vous demande
ayons confiance en nous en mars 2020
vous aurez à faire un choix
le bon choix pas quitter personne prend
décision à la plaza choisissez la liste
rivière pilote en action avec à sa tête
denis louis régis parce que nous devons
mettre le piloter au centre des
décisions chaque piloter doit être un
acteur un artisan du développement de sa
commune parce que tout monde c'est mon
voilà et donc raymond théodose vous
terminer l'exercice à vous de conclure
pour terminer je voudrais dire donc au
pélousse un dock que des dés l'entrée
des malades qui en 2014 à la tête de la
ville avec mon équipe nous avons surtout
mis le piloter l'humain au centre de
notre nombre de relations avec des
accompagnements
il ya aussi une chose puisqu'on pas de
démocratie participative
effectivement nous avons eu à mener en
coupe même à rivière-pilote et puis il
ya ceux qu'on ne voit pas aussi ce qu'on
ne voit pas je vois le candidat sur la
tête nous avons fait quand même beaucoup
de choses que je ne vois pas le souhait
ce que l'accompagnement de notre
jeunesse
à travers le ccs les sommes que nous ce
que nous faisons la réception déjà
l'accompagnement que nous faisons avec
aussi de l'association du bout des
commerçants donc je voulais je voulais
donc demandé donc assez piloter nous
sommes où nous étions sur le terrain de
nous permettre de permettre à la
dynamique pilotine de continuer le
travail qu'il a commencé avec la liste
conduite pas vraiment et au dos merci
messieurs des bains épique mais reprend
ce soir ce qui nous promet de belles
joutes pour les semaines prochaines
pas trop aborder cette histoire il n'y a
pas de signe à qualifications n'ont pas
revenir là dessus
s'il vous plaît on termine demain demain
on signale que en télévision le débat
concernera la ville du marigot
voilà le prochain débat télévision lui
rivière pilote je ne crois pas non en
télévision non je ne crois pas le
prochain rendez vous sur la radio et sur
le site web ce sera vendredi prochain
donc
enfin vendredi qu'il vient de cette
semaine voilà merci kelly d'avoir
commercialisé cette émission merci à
vous des fêtes
élections municipales le débat